[Musik]
ich bin kein traum natürlich nicht sagte
der kommentator der einmal mehr meine
gedanken gelesen hatte eigentlich bin
ich eher so etwas wie ein erwachen
[Musik]
ganz zentraler satz unter vielen sehr
schön setzen in hochmoor kam ist neuen
roman die ermordung des kommentatoren
teil 1 der zweite teil erscheint im
april das ist ein satz der sehr
vielseitig ist ja in viele richtungen
ausstrahlt und der eigentlich einen
prozess beschreibt in dem der erzähler
der namenloser zähler in diesem roman
gerade steckt er ist maler
er ist in ganz furchtbare bedrängnis
seine frau hat ihn verlassen was
überhaupt nicht wohin mit sich er weiß
nur so kann es nicht weitergehen erfährt
erst mal ein paar monate ziellos durch
japan dann mietet er sich in einem haus
ein in den bergen in dem vorher ein
berühmter maler gewohnt hat und dann
kommt etwas in ihm in bewegung er merkt
dieser art von gebrauchskunst villa
nicht mehr kann er nicht mehr
und dann kommt er in begegnung mit einem
geheimnisvollen bild was der berühmte
maler der in diesem haus gewohnt hat
dort zurückgelassen hat was sich daraus
entwickelt ist dann typisch murakami
da spielen geistergeschichten mit rein
da spielt die große unsicherheit des
helden mit rein das kennen wir aus
vielen roman von programm was wir nicht
kennen ist diese genaue beobachtung
eines künstlers das heißt viele dieser
setzte die dort fallen kann man eins zu
eins wenn man so will
vom maler auf einen schriftsteller
übertragen
und das macht diesen roman so
interessant das heißt murakami schildert
einen maler er spricht aber kann man
annehmen denn vieler hinsicht von ihr
selber